this new agreement is the fruit of weeks
of negotiation between London and
Brussels addressing four crucial areas
relating to Northern Ireland that the
customs territory v80 law border checks
whether there should be any and what
means of democratic consent there will
be for this new agreement let's start
with customs so under this agreement
Northern Ireland leaves the European
Union customs union along with the rest
of the UK but in practical terms
it'll be treated as if it was still in
the European Union that effectively adds
a border in the Irish Sea and that
effectively means any commercial goods
passing from Great Britain into Northern
Ireland that end up in the south in the
European Union will be subject to EU
tariffs that the UK will have to collect
and what about VOT on that Northern
Ireland remains in the European Union's
v80 system for the UK's HMRC is tax
collectors will have to collect the
money that at the very least adds
another layer of bureaucracy now what
about border checks how will this be
police we know there can't be border
checks on the land border but there will
be checks at these Northern Ireland
ports land Belfast and Warren Point
it'll be UK officials who'll be doing it
effectively policing the borders of the
EU single market finally democratic
consent the most vexed issue of all the
process by which the people of Northern
Ireland will give their support or
withdraw it from this new trading
relationship every four years the
Stormont Assembly will vote and a simple
majority will be required can to
continue the arrangements or end them
crucially neither the Nationalists all
the unius communities will have a veto
now all of that is just to secure the
withdrawal and allow the UK to begin
trying to secure the prize as Boris
Johnson would have a its own trade deals
around the world starting with the
European Union now in the political
declaration today both sides agreed to
go for a comprehensive and balanced free
trade agreement ensuring there are no
tariffs fees or charges now that's the
goal but negotiations over this
potentially even more complex
and over the last three years can only
begin if this withdrawal deal is
approved